behind his coup attempt was the feta
terrorist organization America and
sylvania they are seein the leader of
the sterilization is residing in the
United States of America Pennsylvania
Roberto unreality and making it a lot
like you behind that so we don't know
who's is backing this up but we will
investigate that further as you say
Gulen resides in the United States in
the days since the coup your government
has detains more than 13,000 people
across all aspects of society tens of
thousands have been dismissed from their
jobs or suspended from their jobs is
that purge now over I have so much to my
i love devon magician let's continue I
don't know what there could be the
process is not completed yet site would
it have on us Turkish relations if the
United States doesn't excite America
village directory Leveson Kirk Lucas
kill enemies multi-channel all I using
then our net America and every city she
let it supplied much TV you're like it
thanks Omar makwana better Corrado some
a contact unit sign over oh my gosh can
I provide the best I and then yeah they
domesticated return items below he's no
cache partition needs to be extradited a
short leash at all the details with them
and from this mission I'll measure on
you in a community shoes no sorry judges
of the USA meanings you and I am sure
about do you still hola Yosh on the
controller
seen that we have experiences resident
there have been suggestions in the past
few days that perhaps the United States
or elements of the United States
government might have had forewarning of
the Ku they might have received
intelligence that this coup was going to
be launched and they failed to notify
your government do you hold any
credibility in those statements a
blinder there may be less Nazi doctor
later my mother's face in my room is
America did you partner what about
Turkey's punch sit with the EU
jean-claude Juncker has said that there
is now a little chance of Turkey joining
the EU anytime soon it doesn't sound
particularly good for your government
from that perspective does it I mean
what is your reaction to what he had to
say I didn't mean that this is a serious
Charlie come up with this kind of
navigation quite frequently and it
responsibly got logic normal thank you
to be honest job you get that yes
harmonic oscillator colliding with is
such an atrocity the fact that do they
keep up their fingers here Pakistani
very solid publicly on sorry but it is
all buzzing designs take care too much
let me show that to cater country
operation is Diana we are very loose
raging anything for a pitching machine
standard a nice but no allegiance fine
with the precious blood from a suitcase
you will not be created to such
allegations this is a suggestion in a
column in one of the Turkish newspapers
this morning that perhaps there is less
support for the European Union in Turkey
now than there was some years ago of
course it's not what doesn't come in
regulation of turkey does people
remember to the heirs and heiresses want
to become a bike there are people or you
wanted to come up back like an
introduction shishio's am I wanted to
kill then another kid dressed on the
other half the others opinion of them we
can actually questioned your project for
the last 15 years for the last five
decades yonkers comments yesterday were
based around the prospect of Turkey
reintroducing the death penalty will
turkey rich to the death penalty Turkey
has experienced very important very
seriously vent we have 256 martyred send
you the time we have 2187 people who
have been wounded tragedy ocean and we
experience tonga I career be done
jerseys on are coming out on the streets
there for the teen babe and introduced
this is the gabby demo ought to be here
almost a few is a democratic country we
are governed line democracy granular our
request of the nation and be contracted
he done with Hector when I yes yes yes
but how do you judge
manual is not going to happen overnight
ok ok we will be introduced it to talk
to what yes yes because then they are
also rushing us again it can be won't
watch be reached with other hope you no
matter hello emotional romantic weekend
together justice because turkey is a
state or block will you listen to the EU
so you listen to your citizens with
regards to the possible imposition of
the dead fantasy would you listen to
what the EU is saying if the EU says we
don't want you to impose his resume let
them as you didn't it anja medication to
know I citizen as a wash Columbus and
then we will listen unless what you say
to the nato secretary general when the
military has all parts of the military i
should say have attempted a coup against
the government how do you reassure nato
that on a military-to-military level
things are ok the nadorian we can
properly it was not intentional der
Turkish Armed Forces a scary new policy
we are fatigued en terrorist lubin
amazon alleges karppinen the members of
the sterilization are used the tanks at
the end on the helicopter all the church
how did you get out your mission unity
Zola delegates use medicine hi chefs
intervene noble not attempted kisses are
you take over the rotas may have been
made oddly to native countries no
reassure kids are ya to NATO you learned
this productos Julio many years and here
at random
nationalistic sausage pasta not really
not oh no I didn't say security for name
is not rollin to awaken a sinner learner
with a nice salad or something I don't
know we're not the country that is
possible what do you thank us TM x is
the British government the new British
government a government that you can do
business with doom relations between
Turkey and UK a very deep roots circle
each other's so we can work with that
thank you i wish my dad make and her
children although the deep encounter
professor and former mayor challenger we
met Kristin there's not fully respected
d in a memory of his godfather which is
not i own a company to do this can work
and we will accept him as he you know
like him Kim bad time to mom can since I
just really love letter recently hey
because it's just the statement I Jack
god I love each other and we do know
that he will not to cause any big errors